standing
[Music]
the Kardashians had a very Merry
Christmas party with a Little Help from
Kim's daughter North and Sia yeah
multi-grammy nomineesia people
[Music]
I don't know what's going to top that
Courtney and Travis Barker hosted the
famous fam's annual holiday bash over
the weekend Merry Christmas everyone and
thanks to Chloe fans got an inside look
at the over-the-top Soiree I mean you
guys
are we okay pretty safe to say we're not
okay just check out that festive
entryway complete with a gorgeous
fireplace ornate rugs velvet curtains
and twinkly lights and lots and lots of
Christmas trees you guys unlike the
first one here because I was so excited
uh yeah we can see why because inside
the party guests were greeted with
cocktails before entering a massive
clear tent with hanging floral
arrangements gorgeous holiday decor and
impressive dessert table and a ball pit
for the kiddos it's such a beautiful
thing and speaking of kiddos Kim and
Kanye West's nine-year-old daughter
joined Sia at the mic for a performance
of the singer's holiday track Snowman
[Music]
thank you
impressive right northie might just have
a future in music like her dad no matter
what they want to do in life I hope that
they work really hard but North wasn't
the only Kardashian kiddo at the party
that skin with her four kids North Saint
Chicago and Psalm as well as her brother
Rob's daughter dream just slip a sable
under the tree for me Kylie Jenner
shared that clip with her daughter
stormy dressed in matching outfits and
Coco she coordinated with her daughter
true too rocking red ensembles
and get this Chloe shared a sweet and
rare snap with true and her
five-month-old son whose name she has
yet to reveal so far it's going good
he's perfect oh thank you he looks just
like true Chloe and her ex Tristan
Thompson welcomed their son in July via
surrogate but they called it quits last
year after news broke that the NBA star
had fathered a child with another woman
now that my son is here I get to move on
I think a lot of what is in the media is
sort of things that we feel we need to
film because it's in a way unfair to the
viewers if they don't get to see things
and it seems all is Merry and bright
because a source tells E.T Chloe and
Tristan are doing a great job at
co-parenting quote things can be tricky
at times but they are doing their best
and are taking things one day at a time
and all that Echoes what Chloe told E.T
about raising kids back in 2019. I think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
the source adds that true is so amazing
as a big sister and already shares a
special bond with her baby bro
[Music]
and when it comes to Chloe finding love
our source says she's definitely open to
it but she's also prioritizing her
little ones a sentiment she shared with
E.T back in 2019. I'm just super happy
and content and I'm focused on true I
just I'm having so much fun with her and
what I want to I will
foreign